おつかれさまでした
これからですこんにちははじめ社長です
20時間いいたビュー生活
どーすかも服装
謝罪はい
意識しております私は思ったんですよね
これから僕がユーチューバーとしてそして
いち社会人として訪れるであろう質疑応答
と絶対この後ある伴田そういう機会謝罪
会見する可能性もあります
てほしくはないで僕もあってほしくはない
ですでまつ毛エクそういうしっかり
インタビューする機会があると思うので
アイ結構効いあるんですよね間違ったこと
言ってもダメだぜいたらしい部分には
なきゃいけないそうと気付かにするんです
けどもそのインタビューを24時間耐え
しのげばめちゃくちゃ俺なんか強くなる
から僕人としてなるでちょっとあの未知の
領域なんですけども今から24時間
インタビューされ続けてみたいと思います
謝罪会見的なテイストでやばいって本当
ねえそして24時間インタビュー答え切っ
た際にはもうすっげえ気持ちいいと思うん
ですよやりきったというもその気持ちが
高ぶりまくってると思うんですよなので
24時間のインタビュー終わったあとに
すぐ
りゆーろびてい
ビール飲み店では多少かわっパパのビール
は格別や格別あってかやってることも格別
だし終わった後かけるんですよそういう
わけでこの厳しいチャレンジの達成後に
アサヒスーパーぐらいを飲みたいと思い
ます
で今回ですねスーパードライが発売36年
目ということでなんと初のフルnew ある
されたとのことですよめでとうございます
最高に気を付けた変わる瞬間に飲むと
たまらないビデオと思うので24時間
終わった達成感とともに伸びたいと思い
ますガリバー
軽い
そして今回ですねただ20時間
インタビューしてるんでしょうかもしれ
ないと思う間違い動画的には地獄絵図
これを用意しましたおおやおやこれはどこ
かで見させなさい頃ですねこちらをですね
はい3時間に1回来るチャンスがあります
1から僕の目があるのではいまず市が出
たらはい1時間
誰か後退することに第5子と交代します
その1時間はオラや滑るってことでそうだ
まあまあ1時間だけでも後半だと助かるな
とにが出た場合
横になりながら
質疑応答できます走るコートブレーキは
割れないなさん金だって入っ
何もなしですマジかさんだけ聞かないよう
にします4が出た気配で質問が超スローん
なっちゃう
向こうのねそうねちょっと本でいいね時間
稼げそうそうだねめっちゃゆっくり喋る
から俺も休めそうにしても聞いてないんだ
もん以後かで彼はいアジア君が逆に質問
できるか逆に疲れない日かねこっちが生ん
でブロックはいサイコロの母かける1時間
初めて2階の時が止まります
[音楽]
なるほど実質休み塗装もう1回振ってこと
に6が出た後に設け振って出た目の分
時間が止まる止まる
それは動画的にを引きたい1時間に1回常
に触れないんでそうで最初のゼロズばない
から7回触れるって事ますずっと多分24
時間も伴ってと思ってヤバイと思うんで
食事とかは鉄器で撮らせて頂きますはい
それはそのインタビュー中なんですけども
縮図とパー取りながらちょっとに図鑑かま
せていただきますじゃあ
終始始めて言っています
[音楽]
本日は
ame
10時間
では
宜しくお願いします回収
ございますね
[音楽]
頭痛がして
と思っ
社会性として
失業
能力を実業まして
強いのっていた力を負った
てい
使っておりますか
必要かと
あのー妻ここなんですけれども
現在の率直なを登頂プラ製以外はござい
ません
気持ちと言いだせますけどあー
詰まって撃っ
にぶつかって近況等
第二ていただいているを
たそうなこれはー
大丈夫だと思う
ですかん
イェーガー必要なくとどうなるのかと
うわぁ
なものを
表面にはあります
の完成
トニオ
[音楽]
姫ビール美味しいさです
24時間3 part 2
自分がどういう余地をするのかという名の
時点でやっていただいてもよろしい
その皆さん僭越ながら指定箇所ですね
ああああああ
ああああああああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
籐工芸どのポイント
ウィッグといたしましています
インタービューでも謝罪玄関の可能性さ
せるようにを規制が黒いとへ
不明止め挙げさせていただき戦艦ですので
かっこいいポーズをお願いいたします入っ
てしまいましたん
me
ありがとうございます
porcelain ん
ん
[音楽]
ちょっと石油探査て
指定します
ええええええ
all other 車
を築けそうです
天至尊香川かなっただけでた柱が立ったの
で変換のサイコロタイムでございますいや
頼むよあんずデイ
とってさん以外だったら何でも嬉しいと
思うからそう一発勝負でいきますはいん
マッハん
ています
んでっ
プー
あったん
アンカー
[音楽]
引き続きよろしくお願いしますん
ん
ええええええ
していません
[音楽]
顔相俺が居場所使うと使う
していた
goo
これする小出量も2
方々が自分た展示物
ん
訴えたいですよ
うん
八葉室もたっさんしてくれるはいおれ
ベッドを食べるからちょっと長めの日本
募集中
けどタイヤ戦略
希望を大
voodoo
いやー
[音楽]
ございます
予選2回目のサイコロたんです
無理だよ
結構6時間ずっと質問勢が続いて質問の
内容を向こうお骨を引き出しがないので
結構失業とで地獄のような感覚になってき
た
何番街ましょう
3位がさんで箸で終わるいきますはいさー
[音楽]
ああああああgo ここここ喜ばれそう
ですねこれ
はーい
ran
医者のか接続をします今日はよろしく
me皆さんを
[音楽]
あああん
歩道が延びて返され
ame
[音楽]
ashandan
さあ
夜も深まってもいません
この3時間は俺が話すんじゃなくて聞きず
に回れたので脳が疲れなかったですでは
それは
スローインを願います
インチから降ろしたいです
re 入れ
day
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
おおおお
goo
dare
ん
me
入っています
例が悪くなったけるようなどともあります
か
ゲーム数
あった
それに関してはまずは単刀せられてますね
では何故
1されるございます
お母様にいます少しでも考えた
[音楽]
oha
re sure
おそろい
ございません
分かってるじゃないですかんdare
[音楽]
ほどいらっしゃれば
はライター
cat 上昇しております聞いています
me
p 4
ん
i am
十条の発言できると思いません
[音楽]
そうですよね
出題ております
新鳥栖フォーラムせたい
ません
敵ではない10人7位から始め車
どうなるん
人気人カツ
20全力支援だと思いますね数珠渠景
ないという注意
環境オーナーをつくって
ちょっとずつを空気を張ったりございます
週2時間が経過しました
400のおかげで一時間休みます
ありがとうございますさっと声がになれば
かなり俺だったされます右麻布
俺買えないぞ
[音楽]
ああああああ
tan
[音楽]
届いていっ不調
いやー
たらそれ質疑音を引き続きアヌいくので
ただの態度悪いあ記者会見でいきましょう
[音楽]
偶然大変お待たせいたしました引き続き
実業と方にを愛しませんです
入っていませんni
そう月22時間近く伊勢に座っ
いったこともありまして
かなりアートだと言いますか
新関西なものがいい
大きい方とか作れます
[音楽]
ん
続と疲れてきたんで銀なが便器になる言葉
おった
[音楽]
かしこまりましたその後ビュー air
俺も ok ですか
あっはっは
賛成はちょっと夢の中をいろいろしてい
ます
ん
ちょっと外人日本させていただきますん
入れなかったさあ
よくになっている部分は休めたんですけど
いいえに質問くる
鬼が9時間ですかねこっちに一気には結構
横になって寝れる気分になっているので1
だしてしまいたいと思っておりますそれで
はお願います
pa た
[音楽]
サイコロのかつ格別力森内かが止まります
ね
お願いします
はいりませんね
猫が放たれてっ
いいいいいいいいっ
あああああこれにわー
1時間
一君以外の違いません
[音楽]
スいう意味鬼無里て患者様じゃん
背負わせいたしました
朝すぐ失業の方
2名の設定インターが大きい
3大ツールでしょうか
9分
でい
[音楽]
売る以外の鹿が捉えルー
[拍手]
mar20ん
[音楽]
gooana 機が面白いではい0兆とか
そば
ねえ良いです
me
するほど良いです
4いう
エイ
5月だぞ
広がった
の子さんってさ
それを
あああああ背が高いん
猫あっているが高いですね
今するまでそれで興奮していっ
name 合成者様かっていうふうに言わ
れているパーカーだがあるぞ
のみですからん
[音楽]
俺は
残された事が
[音楽]
これ
時間が経過しました目の焦点が合っている
んですけどネットがこたえている状況です
たでしょうさあと2階個人的にはもう
ちょっとカッコ休まないと末で最後にいけ
ないですよ
鈴木一致からくださいん
そうですねいうと言いますはい
tan
ああああああ
yeah
おったんですけど誰かと交代って書いたん
だけどそしたら洋平君じゃなくてもいいん
ですよバレンザ活かしましょう
[音楽]
大丈夫かよっています
par
[音楽]
22通常の
wh
いいです皆さんユーザー
始め体操第一良いとさせていただきます
薄い今日はでね右に剃りましょう
はいっ
お腹の横の姫えているのを実感して
ください
もどって三いい
いいいいいい
たこば集
はぁ
ame
駅発車します
ん
点数1時間が経過します残り3時間です
いやもう何かヤバいんですよ結構その記者
さんと仲良くなってきちゃってあっ会話の
歯止めが利かなくてめっちゃくちゃ絶対
喋っちゃいけないなことを話してますと
思った分脳が追いついてないというか
最後保釈後に気を使います
長います入っだぜはいっ
[音楽]
ここに来てそれで裁判
いつも超スローになるということで気も
強く質問にしっかり答えて言ってゴールし
たいと思います頑張っています
おっ
風祭いたしましたーーーいます
he
ああああああ
[音楽]
ハイッ
結果が大きい変わっていっぱーてーあり
ます
まずぜバダ郁子くっついたいっ
けども飲んでから何が欲しくなるかという
110 c なということなのっ
こんな自分を止められる見ないと思います
[音楽]
ああああああああ g
ウェイ
したら
中央
わー
を
ああ
tan
姫城で
[音楽]
ch
ん
[音楽]
烏来
もう1死を最後は6個
エンヴィー
わー
食べています頑張ってくださいいます
[音楽]
皆さん月職業をよろしくお願いしますね
と中身は妻のままで
伝令810歳の測り方ないと思うん
味わいで反対すごくなどでてu 首に当て
尋常小学校
ちょっとこの
セーブデーターを持ったものが今回10代
後半から始めたいんだという気持ちが強く
て
j
最大な民主強い
二考えてに手伝いていなかったすごい店長
が悪くって
ブーシェw 30
点満点で上がるとしたりは自分になって
いるという
うーむ
75ですね
asf
願ってしまったんだけど
くれません
ただて今でもプーチン
ありがとうございません
jr と思っています
一強いでるっ
みなさま長い時間帯がございましたいて
真面目そう記者会見を終わらせていただき
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
というわけでようやく
24時間インダビュー無事に終わりました
th
これは凄いよ運動量すらも少ないものです
ね人と24時間話し続けるということの
大変さというかインタビューので向こうの
質問に答えるっていう脳みそが常に改定し
ている感じが本当に大変でしん大敵とより
精神的にやり切ったという感じでもう俺は
やり切りました今日はというわけでこの時
を待っていましたようやく止めます
こちら発売36年目圧のフルリニューアル
で新しくなったスーパードライでスーパー
トライと言えばやっぱりこのシルバーの
デザインしねマジでカッコイイですそして
こちら裏面にはですね新しいスーパー
ドライのうまさを表現した辛口カーブ最初
で順でくるので新しいのはこちらから口の
コンセプトはそのままに初めて味を品評し
たそうですでは早速飲んでいるでしょう
この達成感で溝のまずうまいと思うよ
the 開けます
もうおいしいでは24時間インタビュー
達成記念
がんばーい
10分
ん
フープ
4日
いう
どう言えばいいんだろうな
もう
オレンジしかわかんないよを達成各しかも
このオイスター
[音楽]
ん
最高やっぱりスーパー取れて飲んだ瞬間と
のみ答えがすごいありますし瞬時で感じる
切れの予算飲んだ瞬間
きましたもう
持っていた
ペプ止まらこの躍動的な甘さこそ新しい
から曲らしいですねもう何か企画も本当
結構心折れそうなぐらい精神的にキツかっ
たんですけども無事達成できてこの最高の
達成感のともにのもスーパードライはマジ
でおいしいね新しくなったスーパーとね
詳しい内容は動画概要欄にありますので
ぜひチェックしてみてくださいみんなも何
以下をやりきったときぜひ数パートナーで
乾杯しましょう
アサヒスーパーカーわーい
ブーブー
[音楽]
l パッケージん